you're using wood next to lava nice
going up oh my god well I'm getting like
Owen by everything skilling TP to me no
I'm just getting killed Achilles died
all right there we go did you pull did
you put the iron in the chest uh I put
like six art so I'm going to I'm going
to make a little thing right here and
I'm gonna put the lava in it Oh more
iron right here and I'm going to put the
lava in it so then I can use my buckets
to get more of it actually I think we
just make another bucket that probably
be the cydia here um does anyone have an
extra spoon pick on them yes okay no I
have a would pick you want them all my
broke oh that's the poopy one that I'll
strike to take the blue one okay oh yeah
that's not coming to strike her that's
good he just was here hello I'm here now
if you back all right well almost all
the iron is done cooking no I lied
almost all the iron is not gonna cook in
all right I got a 13 more I catch good
i'm gonna i'm making another bucket to
get more lava yeah i do that do it you
should I think we should focus on the
swords and armor for instance before
make look it oh well I already made it
so how many buckets did you make I'm I
have to one of them is filled with lava
one of them is not you waste but 6-iron
god damn it yeah it make sure we get
enough for everybody I will not make any
more buckets so what's 26 x 36 times do
I have a calculus 13 GG what he says
achieves you I don't know why wait so
you quit
78 we got at this oh all day know why
crappy oh crap oh I said crappy yo like
the wasn't hi yes capio orly alright so
now we have two buckets of lava okay I'm
pretty good with all the book Oh what
that why why why why did you spawn I was
freaking getting lava it's probably not
a good person to TP onto I needed to get
back to the place with the furnace care
so many holes everywhere god damn it get
rid of this why are you eating my bad
what you eat so let's throw that in
there and then some here I get two more
coal you're not okay so what do we have
go ahead and make swords chest plates
pants boots and then helmets I'm gonna
make swords first it's probably good
idea um and you would Jeannie would I
got your wood son boom time is 14 to
isla forget hurry um here let me know
your couple oh oh the quick quick quick
that is nothing wait I gave you six
Kabul okay you guys can we help you so
what piece of armor should I get first
trolls um chest chest hey its boots
helmet I'm not an app for chest unless
someone throws me one more piece of
iphone Oh were you red beretta it's
don't block in my inventory stuff
someone told me one more piece on it so
I can make this job I would have been
faster if you just you just did the
other thing okay whatever whatever okay
there you go let's see I don't see their
base
uh okay just please in here for both of
you nice let's see if we can find a good
spot for this place do we have any food
uh I don't know it's probably a no then
they probably know yeah I'm making us
pants now need to find a good spot for
this feed he'll there we go haha feet Oh
gonna be short on iron I was only able
to make us chest piece keep matter we
had a few moment we had a minute of jail
if so we're not going out on uh okay
hold me I go down here well uh we can
build our base after the time's up right
yeah yeah alright so I'm building us a
bubble of water pool release one we can
jump down to shark or if you want a
stack of a stock car will come to me ok
tip you mad gives me quick and spawned
you Roger oh there's another one no oh
okay pause it only five pieces anyway
okay two runs doesn't matter okay listen
we're not gonna go too high up on the
sky base cuz I don't want them to be
like that's too huh you too which I
really pretty accurate so Ronnie we were
not able to get the bows we needed oh
that's true I think it's too late oh no
we can always we can always adjust to it
oh yeah we need kill spiders restraining
oh well we are the preparedness why
because we have everything ready to go
oh I have to uh to string oh we have a
bow I lied really 40 we have Bo I like
it's way too early who's gonna be the
doesn't matter you have for something Oh
time up okay I know that that's it now
server so time is 14 15 so what is lying
I'm grabbing our stuff and I'm coming to
you striker wait don't TP a dark lime
okay good I can see spawn will make this
stuff I took I you that you didn't even
bring a lot buckets I got you I got a
lot of buckets they're not here you can
still TP
I'm keeping to you I got that and go
ahead now how's the time you're gonna do
it oh ok yeah I got you stuff just in
case I'm bringing that crap are up sure
whatever that's what we got who what I
wasn't able to make more actually I can
make boots right now did you go to this
worry well I want it but it won't here
huh ok hello oh crap ok find any food
nope one that spawn in five beef for
each player I literally have not seen an
animal all right i'm gonna put down this
crafting table oh oh oh let's hope you
got wandered here um beef one two three
four five there's yours 1 2 3 4 5 that's
mine 1 2 3 4 5 and there's yours I'm
gonna make a chest here major let me see
the limited obsidian who boots awesome i
lava kool kool Flint now let's see what
you're doing this extreme see you big
boy empty glass bottle nice I got some
saplings for it's just in case just in
case uh your string 52 moro an arrow
yeah I know that's ones like right over
there that's good though wait with the
string that's in there I have two levels
do you guys want to try have seven
levels awesome hey we should definitely
go down in the gym do we have a way to
get down yeah there's water pool right
below us this was okay we're gonna get
off um stay up here and if we have
control of respond we can still tell the
border okay wait you should stay up okay
all right well he's got levels um I got
sorry
bubbles will go in in groups again um
mean striker food okay all right ready
set go don't die off failing a jump yes
also kill any chickens if you see him
that would not be a good way to go let's
see if I can did you get your beef I got
my beef I just turned on super far chunk
rendering and it haft my frames okay I'm
doing really good now i got bane of
arthropods nice I got dropped this one
yeah I a protection on my chest plate
okay uh I got power won the boat ok so
is a dark are you saying that you're
gonna be so cute oh that was close i was
close I'll see if mike i'll see you guys
have any more arrows there's one error
on there and there's lots of stuff sorry
striker you want to go to you TP i have
to put your full name is just striker or
is it strike or something but i am oh my
gosh that's why that's why that's
freaking why oh my gosh our sword no
damn me like what the meeting was over
then I was like what here if you have
extra levels can you do my pants mo gute
nacht back 10 y'all crap oh I did it
wrong okay sorry okay yes I I did this
wrong okay i forgot to enchant my pants
in my boots uh I have to UM there's your
pants and I'm gonna chant my pants so
dark if you're not attacking can I
switch towards will do sure okay go up
here LOL protection- my booties all
right protection one on breaking one
projectile projection one and knock back
one not like one is night not bad how
are they doing they taking the time
getting here so we tp'ed back Oh boot
but uh uh uh i neva so you get you give
him sorry uh huh did have enough levels
for your boots haha okay all right then
let's say let's TP their particular or
myself and oh that was those was close
who switch trade the trade is happening
I think I'm gonna round are gonna run
around with his rusty shovel I surprise
p someone else taken out of the lava
bucket if you're not i'm gonna think it
with me okay that's fine think i'm gonna
stay up here so I'll no I'm not I'm not
I don't feel good about the Liao's okay
i think i'm going to go in search for
chickens no yeah well i meant for like
arrows and crap whoa friendly first time
like of the game actually yeah actually
chickens would be a good thing to have
whoa go ahead and like rush him right
now all right there we go if you want to
go just go hard rush i'm fine with as
well but let's um let's go scout let's
go find out with you okay okay um do you
want me to stay the dark Stan turkestan
okay let's go I'm come huh ooh alright
people be talkin to that chat all day
yeah so we we can't / feed though
correct even if you have solid anymore
since it's okay yeah let's go find over
there um and I think they're gonna
probably build like the up on the dome
but yes it be on the dome allowed to big
what to do no I mean like like up
against it oh ok ok like as a very edge
of the mat well they did they did find
diamonds so they are far with he he got
the achievement for dominance I was like
right we're around one you were asking
for beef yeah alright let's see I'm on
top of the trees ya see that I can't
mount up the trees whoo-hoo I'm scoping
my arrows a nice mountain range
so I'm just admiring I like all the
flowers in this update that make me feel
good like myself no I can see the dome
now I can see our base like misty our
base is like in the mist most notable
thing out here I see you dark I see you
two guys over there you and your shining
armor is fairly shiny um monster Wow
slow and I'll take Ithaca lat license
that that was closer to him so he will
have the better chance of seeing it okay
you guys taking this hot lunchable nope
oh they're not o.o dark look out you
might get murder if I'd hi guys I can
still see you guys okay we'll be on the
watch out for them not us well I senior
player all i sees the armor that's it oh
now you both disappeared on me here we
jump down into a little pool hey it
should be on the watch out for the end
out of us at the [ __ ] they went in
this little cave earth her Chancellor
well there's no there's tons of iron
that cave okay you want to if you want
to grab it sure let's have a pic how
would help grab it go okay all right do
I have to go around to get to the
entrance oh oh oh that's striker okay
oh yeah there's like there's like tons
of iron oh there's a zombie yes no we
need 15 I've got six um I'll get this
one how much did you get right there I
got to you too I got 10 laughs right I'm
tong 11 i think that's it 1111 to tunis
two more so two more I'm just looking in
the mountain to see if there's a minyan
don't see any immediate oh so stressful
this is luck what's gonna happen i am
becoming nighttime oh really is i don't
see them and they don't have a base of
like on the surface maybe they can't go
for the scott a standard and you'd have
a base up with her obsidian well yeah
but kinda be underground or not know
your ok this will this guy by like three
sides oh oh we got visible from six yeah
I've lost you guys yeah where were we
you shouldn't be able to see us we're
like sideways from the base I'm beside
me I base is like x for x it's a four by
four foot score man bye bye bye Oh what
wrecked I said four sided
you